in the last chapter
we looked at least squares regression or
prediction
what we're going to do now is look at a
different form of prediction
and that's going to be when the thing
you're predicting takes on a finite
number of values like you know
true or false that's called
classification and we'll see how that
works in this lecture and we'll also see
how to do it
using least squares so we'll start with
what classification
is so basically it's data fitting
with an outcome that takes on um
typically non-new numerical values like
true or false or
spam or not spam or dog horse or
mouse right these are um
these are examples it could be different
variations of a disease or something
like that that you're trying to predict
now in this case the output values are
called either
labels it's kind of obvious why it would
be a label like
a dog that's a dog or categories
and in fact a one way to talk about
outcomes that are non-numerical or take
on a finite number of values
is to say is to say that those are
category that's a categorical
uh variable okay and in this case
instead of uh
you'd say data fitting but basically
what you're trying what it's called is
classification
is is what uh what you're trying to do
now we're going to start with uh the
simplest and frankly the by far the most
common case which is so-called
boolean uh classification and that just
says there's two possible
outcomes and you know these could be for
example true
and false or spam not spam
or something like that right um and
uh so there we're going to encode them
numerically as plus 1 is going to
represent a true
for us and false is going to be -1. now
by the way there's other there are other
encodings a very common one
is 1 is true and
is is false that's another very common
and
numerical encoding of boolean or truth
values
and so the classifier is going to look
like this it's actually going to be a
function
it's going to take in an n vector those
are going to be our feature values
and instead of spitting out a number the
way
a prediction model does um what it's
going to spit out
is either minus 1 or plus 1. plus 1
means
i think the outcome is true
minus one means i think the outcome is
false so that's kind of the that's the
idea
um okay now there's a ton of
applications of this
um so we already already hinted at one
email spam detection right so here
the way that might work is your feature
vector x would contain
features of an email message it could be
it could encode word counts it
uh it could encode the origin
of that email and things like that um
and that those are just the features
associated with that email
and then of course what we're trying to
predict is is that email spam or not
spam
okay and we'd get a lot of data because
if somebody clicks on spam moves uh
moves an email message to a spam folder
we can assume that she or he
uh is considering its spam okay if they
don't and we have some evidence that
they actually read it
we can assume it is not spam okay
another one this is a huge industry is
financial transaction fraud detection
so for example for a credit card um
so here what would happen is that x
would contain
features of the proposed transaction
like what do you buy
how much is it what time is it what's
the store all that kind of thing
and then also the initiator so the
person
alleging that it's their credit card
right and that would
we'd get all sorts of things like you
know who are they how old are they
you know uh what's their sex where do
they live you know
all sorts of things so all of that would
be wrapped up together in one feature
vector
um and then your job is to look at all
those features
and to say that's uh that's a fine
transaction
yep that that i think that's fine or you
would say i think that might be fraud
now here this is what people would call
an imbalanced
data set meaning that well we hope that
99 you know
ton like 99.9 percent maybe more of the
transactions are actually valid
and a much smaller number are fraudulent
oh i make one minor comment
this usually works in practice i can
tell you actually how this works
so for fraud detection a very common
thing is a red yellow
green uh so it's actually three-way
classification and what happens is
uh a transaction comes in if it's green
it just
it it's accepted and the transaction
goes through if it's red it's blocked
immediately
right meaning it's reasonably confident
that's not right
if it's yellow that transaction is
routed to a human being
who take who looks at it and looks at it
and goes oh i see what's going on here
yep now i remember yep she's traveling
in barcelona and
this this okay that's more than she
would normally spend
for a hotel but it looks okay to me
right so okay back to our main story
sorry
um document classification so suppose i
wanna i would just like to say
find me among these uh
25 000 documents the ones let's try to
figure out
are they is it on politics or not
that'd be it um x
could be a word count histogram in in
that case
okay uh disease detection so here x
would contain patient features
it would include the results of medical
tests it would include symptoms things
like that
and then your job would be to say does
this patient have this specific
disease and then you would guess it
you'd make a guess
it also comes up in a digital
communications receiver so
there what happens is uh x the feet it
well it's not called thought of a
feature vector there
but it is actually it's it's what it's a
received signal
um it could be measurements of a
received signal at different antennas or
spaced in time that that would be the x
and then why is it transmitted bit it's
either true or false
right so um and then you would look at
the received signal and try to guess
if it's true or false now typical ones
in practice are going to have a
you know are going to be accurate like
more more than 99
of the time which is good so okay these
are just applications of
classifiers which is just data fitting
with a categorical
with a categorical uh label or
um outcome right and and we're focusing
for now on boolean outcomes
okay now there's some interesting
differences between this type of
classification
and uh and predicting a number um
uh so let's see what that is um for if
you have a data point that's a pair xy
but remember y is either like minus one
or plus one meaning
false or true um and then we have a
predicted outcome y hat equals
f hat of x it's just a function we
evaluate it we either get plus one or
minus one
that's our prediction now the the way we
measured errors
uh in predicting a an outcome that was a
number was
you know like by the rms value or the
square or the
you know it's just how far off are you
if it's one point if the true value is
1.2 and we guess 1.3 we're off by 0.1
here it's interesting because both the
true value and the guess
only take two values each of them only
takes the value minus one or plus one
altogether you've only got four
possibilities and so
there's only four things that can happen
in this case in a boolean classifier
let's see what they are
so one if we call that a true positive
why remember is the actual value of the
observed data and this says
that this is so true positive means it
really was positive
and by the way and we guessed it was
positive
so positive is another way to guess uh
to say it's plus one
okay um true negative right
um and true negative means it was minus
one
meaning you'd say that you'd say that
that data sample is in the negative
class or
you know whatever has a negative label
um and also guess what
we guessed it and so in these two cases
two of the four cases
were right that's this is a case where
we guessed
and we were we were right notice here
it's actually kind of cool uh we don't
really
expect in another prediction you know
and if i'm predicting the temperature
tomorrow at 1 pm i don't expect it to
get it right to within
you know whatever you know four digits
right not at all but here you know
you're just right i mean you guessed it
right uh now let's get to the
two depressing cases this is called a
false positive
so false positive is this it was really
negative their data point was really
negative that's what y equals minus 1
was
but we guessed it was positive so
basically we're saying
according you know our model is saying
uh
we think you have the disease uh now
the truth is you don't um yeah by the
way
the consequences of that you i think you
can imagine
need not be good right um okay so that's
called a false positive
you can also have a false negative um
that says
it's actually positive but we're
guessing we're like yeah you're fine go
home
yeah couldn't be couldn't be better yeah
go ahead you know um
so that's a false thing that's also you
know obviously
can have very bad consequences as well
a false positive for example in fraud
detection
means that you attempt to buy something
or attempt to carry out a transaction
and it's blocked
right usually then you get something on
your phone that texts you and says hey
is this really you are you really trying
to buy that or something like that
um false negative is interesting
that's when a well that's when a
fraudster uses you know
actually studies your transaction well i
don't think they really do this but
it means that somebody it's actually a
fraudulent transaction and the
the the uh classifier is like yeah
that's cool yeah whatever
sure fine that's a false negative um
okay
so uh in this obviously in the first two
cases the prediction is right
and then in the other two cases it's
wrong um now many different fields
have names for these different things
depending on the specific application
and
um i think another name for being right
and wrong
is no sorry uh these are for the errors
right
one of these is referred to as a type
one error one is a type two error
i i can't remember which is which and so
you just have to ask when you're in one
of those situations right like
what is type 2 error why can't you just
say false negative which seems to me
clear
but whatever that's fine okay
now what happens is if i have a data set
and this could be a test set i mean our
training set i mean it doesn't make any
difference
um and i have a classifier um what it is
is i will calculate
then for each of these x's i will
calculate
y hat uh i
which is going to be f hat of x
i right and so that's our guess and
so basically for each data point we have
two things we have
the true value of y which is minus one
or plus one and we have our guess which
is minus one or plus one
and we divide all our data into these
four different categories of the four
possible things that can happen and we
put them in a matrix like this
and so um so and by the way uh
depending on the field you're in you
would either look at this matrix
or or a transpose of the matrix and that
even tells a lot about you know
whether you took who knows statistics or
machine learning or whatever
did you learn it in computer science or
blah blah first so but nevertheless
this and this thing is called a
confusion matrix which i think is a
wonderful term so let's see what it is
it says you will actually count that's
the number of times so n sub t
p is true positives it's the number of
times in your data set
that it was really true that's what it
means for y to be
plus one and you guessed true so you
were right
um down here that's true negative so
that's the number of times
out of n that's the total number of your
data um total size of your data set
that is the number of times that it was
really false that's what it means to be
in this
second row and you also guest ball so
you were right again
now the off diagonal entries in this
matrix
are mistakes they're errors so
these are the ones that's false
negatives that's where it was
positive but you said no no it's
negative and this is where
here it was negative but you said yeah
it's positive so
these are wrong um so the off diagonal
this whole thing together is called a
confusion matrix which i think is great
uh because you would say things like
here you have
confused class
class one for minus one or something
like that right so
your off diagonal entries tell you about
your confusion
by the way if you had a diagonal
confusion matrix that would be excellent
that means you never made a mistake you
nailed it
okay so the off diagonal things are the
bad ones those are mistakes
diagonal ones are where you're right
okay now people use tons derived tons of
error
metrics uh from you know a data from a
classifier applied to a data set and
you know i'll tell you the ones i think
are the most uh
clearest to me but in fact different
fields use
other names i can't even remember what
they mean any you know like out of the
specificity
and whatever i you know anyway so
you just have to ask and you know one
once you integrate socially into a field
or application area then you'll realize
okay everybody talks about these two
these types of error rates right so okay
so
here's one this is super simple it is
the sum
it is the number of times you were wrong
that's
this one one this is that's this entry
plus this entry those are your error
divided by the total number so this that
makes perfect sense
if that's five percent it means that
five percent of the time
on this data set uh your guess was wrong
that seems pretty clear to me that that
is the so-called error rate
um so people have the true positive or
the recall rate
um is it's the number of true
positives divided by the number of
positives so it's basically
you know depending on the number of po
you know every time when there's a
positive you know what's the fraction of
them that you actually i get them uh you
know
actually get them that way and you would
like that to be
well one would be perfect it would mean
every time there was a true positive
you guess so false positive rate that's
another way to do it
that's called that's the number of false
positives divided by the number of
negatives
so that's that's this that's a false
positive remember is when the
it's truly negative right but you
guessed positive
so it just means among the ones where
it's truly negative how many times did
you accidentally say
oh it's positive so that's it um now
if anyone proposes a classifier and by
the way we have not even mentioned
one method of coming up with a
classifier but
when we do if someone says here's my
classifier
you know you're going to judge it by uh
at least one and maybe two or three
error rates right so you'd say
oh that's a pretty good one it's got a
pretty high true positive rate
you know and a nicely and a reasonably
small
false positive rate or you know oh boy
you know my my classifier has an error
rate of six percent but yours has an
error rate of 12
or something like that so this is the
idea and by the way that's all done
on a test set because doing this on the
training set
is kind of meaningless right so uh but
at that point
you know it it's a it's a real thing
like if you say i can
my false positive rate is this and my
false negative you know that
that and that's on test data that's good
so let's look at an example here's a
spam filter
and this is a test set uh the test set
has about 1300
emails in it and
we can look at this is the truth right
if you look at the row
that's the actual truth and we can see
that you know
uh about 10 of the emails were spam
right because it's 127 versus 1200. okay
i mean you know roughly 1100 um so you
know about 10
of the emails in this data set are spam
um and then let's see how we did
well of the 127 that were really spam
we nailed it on 95 of them we said
that's spam and we were right
now unfortunately uh on 32
of the ones that were spam we were like
we thought about it and
i'm anthropolog anthropomorphizing the
uh classifier we thought the classifier
thought about it and said
no it's not spam but it was um
then we can look at the ones that are
not spam so there are 1139
uh right non-spam emails and
1120 times that's a lot out of 11 39. we
said
we're like that's not spam um but
unfortunately
we classified 19 of those 1100
emails that really were not spam we
classified them as spam
okay so so these are our error rate our
errors of the two different types you
know
and so our error rate would be 19 plus
that's the total number of mistakes we
made out of uh 1266
and it's four percent that'd be one way
to say it
one interesting thing about about that
calculation is
it assumes that these two types of
errors are equally bad
um actually in a lot of cases that's
false
and we're going to come back to that
later later but
that's actually typically false right it
could be that you care much more about
one of these errors than the other
okay so if you want to know what's the
false positive rate
it is out of the ones
uh that were so this is this is as among
all the negative examples of which there
are 11 39
um we falsely thought it was a positive
in 19 cases so
that's we have a false positive rate of
1.67 percent okay
so this is just an example to show what
a confusion matrix is
how do you interpret it and so on right
and if you want a single number
your error rate is as good as anything
else but in fact
a lot of people would look at maybe two
numbers